et on reste amer justement ce direction
cette fois la plateforme régionale de
tri des colis avec le confinement et le
développement du e-commerce l'activité a
explosé plus de trois cent mille paquets
reçus chaque jour à moins de trois
semaines de noël la poste anticipe et
double ses effectifs hélène chapelet
actuellement 330 mille colis sont triés
chaque jour sur cette plateforme de la
poste amer c'est deux fois plus qu'une
année normale 2020 aura été l'année de
tous les records
dès le mois d'avril dernier et le
premier confinement le trafic a doublé
sanaa est intérimaire sur le site loir
et chérien depuis 2010 est au départ
comme 200 autres équipiers saisonniers
elle venait juste en renfort les deux
derniers mois de l'année pour faire face
à l'afflux de colis mais cette année
elle a pu travailler dès trimestre
entier pour que toutes ses commandes
arrivent à bon port
cette année on arrive dans une effectif
que tu es le monde il faut travailler et
plus de personnes ils peuvent venir
travailler et toute la semaine et les
mois entier moi même je suis sûr que je
vais rester ici encore au moins deux
trois quatre mois parce que là on est on
est parti jusqu'à mars au havre il a
soit prêt y aura les roues tour et tout
ça dix mille colis sont traitées chaque
heure sur cette ligne de tri d'un
kilomètre de long le site fonctionne
actuellement sept jours sur sept et
achemine tous ces paquets vers 300
points différents dans dix départements
aux alentours au sortir du black friday
et à 15 jours de noël c'est donc la
dernière ligne droite d'une année
particulièrement chargée
à la fin des vacances de la toussaint en
octobre nous traitions environ 150 160
mille colis par jour
deux semaines après avec les fêtes du
confinement nous étions passés à 330
milles donc en deux semaines
deux semaines doubler les effectifs
doubler le nombre de camions est là avec
le décalage du black friday à la semaine
dernière avec les effets qui vont contre
comment cette semaine on va avoir encore
une croissance du trafic mais pas pas
aussi en pic d'activité que l'an dernier
vu qu'on est déjà sur un plateau qui est
très haut dès le 22 décembre le trafic
va s'effondrer
le temps pour les particuliers de
distribuer tous ses potentiels cadeau le
début de l'année sera ensuite marqué par
le retour des colis et des clients non
satisfaits